there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
sixteen rules for living with less a
free ebook which you can download right
now and the minimalists com /resources
enjoy how do you live a stoic existence
with a family I often get this question
with respect to to minimalism people
were yeah it's easy to say when I first
embraced minimalism I I
I just gotten out of a marriage and and
so I'm married now with a six year old
daughter but at the time it was oh it's
so it's easy for this young single
person to to embrace minimalism try it
with a family but of course the one of
the people who inspired me early on was
a Zen Buddhist
who's a minimalist namely oh boob Alta
and he has six kids and a wife and a
whole minimalist family and what I
realized is that you can and embrace
these different philosophies with a
family it is more difficult however it
does seem to be more important because
you have other people who depend on you
in a way yeah and a family can be a
great source of delight a great source
of joy and yet look at all look at all
the people who have families and simply
ignore the the people in the families
all the people who are too distracted
with other things to really form the
close relationships they could be taking
so stoic is not going to take their kids
for granted not going to take their
spouse for granted not going to take
their parents for granted and is going
to try to extract as much delight as
humanly possible from the situation so
it's compatible with having a family and
that Stoics themselves had different
arguments about whether you should be
going out of your way to have a fan
you're not some youth Sonia's might have
been an outlier there tell me about that
but you look at the other Stoics and
they did so so you say you Sonia si was
against having a family or pursuing it
rather he he tends to think that less is
more but then he there-there's passages
where he talks about going outside and
seeing you know a family with the
parents and the children now it's out in
the sunlight walking together and just
you know the feeling of this is one of
the greatest delights that that a human
being can enjoy and yet think of all the
people who go out with their kids and
it's just a quarrel and everybody's got
their own cell phone they're looking
instead of talking to each other it's
what you make up and you can go into a
family existence and you can turn it
into a really vehicle of self
transformation or not and a lot of
people don't let the fact that they have
a family have any impact on their life
on the way they live in which is tragic